Land und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus du klingst kemenatig
möchte ich sagen ja absolut ich sitze
hier zwischen den hin und her geräumten
Büchern
und mit Entsetzen dass es eigentlich so
nach mehreren Tagen aufräumen nicht
besser aussieht als vorher ah das ist
doch tröstlich warum sollte es dir
besser gehen als allen anderen und ich
sitze wenn es wie ist dein sweetter da
in Düsseldorf bei dir auch so so mehr
mehr mehr grau als sonst was in Hamburg
ist gerade wieder so finster und ich ich
und der der Regen kommt so von vorne a
so beim Joggen sehr unangenehm und ich
ich frage mich immer ob es am Alter
liegt man man ich habe ne gelesen man
kriegt im Alter dünnere hautm ich werde
auf jeden Fall sensibler möchte ich
sagen wetterfühliger ja gut ich bin
nicht nicht ganz so dünnhäutig glaube
ich was das Wetter anbelangt Elter ich
komme ja aus einer kinderreichen Familie
und ich bin ja genau wie du irgendwie
arm aufgewachsen wir hatten ja nichts
und da gehörte auch zu dass in meinem
Zimmer die Heizung nicht aufgedreht
wurde ja kenne ich kenne ich ja ich
hatte ein sehr kleines Zimmer und wenn
man da die Heizung auftrete die keinen
Thermostat hatte dann wurde es heiß und
daraus draaufin beschlossen meine Eltern
das Beste ist die gar nicht aufzudrehen
also auch im Winter nicht und das hat
immerhin dazu geführt dass ich nicht so
dünnhäutig bin sondern mit so einer mit
so einer Art so einer kleinen
klimahornhaut ja gesegnet bin also so in
Drachenblut gebadet habe das heißt da
muss schon ordentlich was passieren bis
mir kalt sehr schön vielleicht ist es
auch einfach nur diese menschliche Wärme
die einem da plötzlich fehlt wenn so
wenn so Winter ist und die und die
Gefühlslage die große so so ist wie sie
gerade ist alle Leute gucken auf dem
Boden draußen und jeder het vor sich hin
und so weiter hast du wahrscheinlich
recht das ist eh die die dann fehlt ja
gen und die macht dich dünnhäutig wie du
da gerade gesagt hast ja genau und weil
du gerade sagst es du baust mir gerade
ohne es zu ahnen eine herrliche
Überleitung Menschen gucken auf den
Boden die gucken ja gar nicht auf den
Boden die gucken ja auf ihr Smartphone
genau interessant ne dieser Tage
Facebook feiert Geburtstag m 2004
gegründet 20 Jahre und ich habe neulich
ein interessanten Satz gelesen von einem
von einem Professor in Stanford glaube
ich der sagte
mit Blick auf Mark Zuckerberg ja auf den
Facebook Gründer die meisten werden nach
der ersten Milliarde nach Tahiti gezogen
nur ein ganz bestimmter Typ Mensch macht
danach immer noch weiter und zckerberg
ist so
einer guten Satz das erinnert mich an
den Spruch von George Soros den ich
glaube ich schon mal zitiert habe der da
lautet also ist wahrscheinlich erfunden
aber ist gut erfunden ja also das George
Soros der N auch Milliardär ist einen
Vortrag gehalten hat und anschließend
kam ein Mann auf ihn zu und sagt darf
ich dir mal was fragen also an ihrer
Stelle wenn ich 3 Millionen hätte würde
ich schon direkt aufhören zu arbeiten
und daraufhin hat George Soros gesagt
das ist der Grund warum sie nie 3
Millionen haben werden ja das heißt also
der der Gedanke dahinter ist man muss
ein Getriebener sein um Milliardär zu
werden und wenn man dann Milliardär
geworden ist dann hört man ja nicht von
einem auf den anderen Tag auf ein
Getriebener zu sein ja das ist sondern
ist das ja so ganz ganz tief in einem
drin und dann ist das auch im Grunde
genommen so der herzschlach der der
einen H und wach sein lässt und
wahrscheinlich ist es auch oft so dass
man alle anderen Dinge im Leben darüber
vernachlässigt hat ne wenn man so
besessen sein Imperium vergrößert hat
und dann fällt einem auch gar nichts
anderes ein was einen erfüllt außer die
weitere Vermehrung dessen was man hat ja
ich ich ich glaube auch da geht's schon
längst nicht mehr um Geld was ich
interessant finde ist Mark Zuckerberg
ist glaube ich 39 Jahre alt
ne und der hat mit mit mit 18 19 Jahren
hat er ja dieses dieses Ding gegründet
die Geschichte kennt ja auch jeder hast
du dam hast den Film gesehen der Social
Network gesehen fand fand ich gut ne es
war war ein guter Film hat auch uscast
gewon also zum damaligen Zeitpunkt war
der regelrecht
ketzerisch war als als der Film rauskam
war Facebook noch irgendwie das
Gute ja und das würde man ja also das
war immer noch in erster Linie hörte man
Facebook in Z sagen mal was für eine
geile Geschäftsidee und wie unglaublich
erfolgreich und von Null auf Millionen
in so kurzer Zeit und so die Stimmung
ist ja seitdem dann doch deutlich
gekippt
das stimmt wann ist die eigentlich nach
deiner Wahrnehmung gegibt wann ist das
eigentlich passiert was würdest du sagen
das ist ja eine atemberaubende
Geschichte das fing ja fing ja an die
haben ja auf dem Kampus da in Harvard
der hat ja durch die Datenbank der der
Uni geknackt das war so so so ein junger
Computer Nerd wenn man so will aus New
York der dann diese Datenbank knackt und
und ein eine kleine aus seiner
studentenbutze so so so eine kleine
Plattform baut auf der er und Tonen die
die Frauen auf dem Kampus bewerten also
hochchauinistisch sexistischer Ansatz ja
bei der Unternehmensgründung ja ich
glaube sogar dass der Name dieses
Registers an der Uni war
Facebook also darauf geht das eigentlich
ursprünglich zurück und äh das haben die
dem dann nach wenigen Tagen wieder
wieder abgedreht das ganze Ding was aber
bei ihm zu gar nichts geführt hat also
nicht im Sinne von jetzt lasse ich das
sondern jetzt fange ich erst richtig an
und dann beginnt dieser atberaubende
Aufstieg
äh und und irgendwann hunderte Millionen
Nutzer und so weiter und ich erinnere
mich an diese an diese großen Deals
eine Milliarde dann für Instagram als er
gemerkt hat okay facebook wird langsam
so ein bisschen ältlich quasi und dann
19 Milliarden für WhatsApp ja um
sozusagen die den die die Inhalte dann
auch auf mobile Endgeräte wirklich zu
transportieren und es war immer die
Frage kriegt man das irgendwie
miteinander vernetzt und miteinander
verzahnt und seitdem ist es dieses
riesige Imperium das es ist verdienen
unvorstellbar viel Geld und was ich so
interessant fand war deswegen wollte ich
mit dir mal darüber reden Medien rich
ganz allgemein gar nicht so sehr
Facebook sozusagen als Bedrohung für die
Demokratie hast du diese diese Anhörung
mitgekriegt ja ich habe so ein bisschen
mitbekommen das ist ja schon das zweite
Mal dass so eine Anhörung stattgefunden
hat genau und das ist t ne was die
amerikanische Politik da mit diesen
mächtigen äh Plattform vertret dann
macht ich meine man denkt immer die sind
die sind sozusagen unbezwingbar und
übermächtig aber dann steht da so ein so
ein Zuckerberg da wie so wie so ein
kleiner Junge und wird richtig links und
rechts abgewarscht ähm hat sich dann am
Ende sogar
entschuldigt äh bei Eltern die da auch
im Saal waren die haben teilweise
Plakate mit Fotos ihrer Töchter und
Söhne hochgehalten und sagt dann ich
bedauere dass sie das alles durchleben
mussten und mit alles meint er und das
einmal kurz zu erklären das Mobbing das
auf seinen Plattformen stattfindet den
äh sexuellen Missbrauch der da auch
gezeigt wird sozialendruck der zu
Essstörungen zu Depressionen teils zu
Suizid führt und so weiter und neben ihm
sitzen die Chefs von tiktok discord
snapchat und x ja also die ganzen großen
sozialen Netzwerke sozusagen alle wenn
man so will auf der Anklagebank das das
war das war eine harte Ansage aber es
wird keine großen Konsequenzen haben
oder ja das ist eben die große Frage ich
ich ich fand halt interessant sag doch
immer wir stellen Werkzeuge zur
Verfügung ne das sagt er seit Ewigkeiten
funktioniert aber nicht mehr weil er
macht ja die Inhalte nicht selber also
ist er aus seiner Sicht für die Inhalte
auch nicht verantwortlich mhm genau ja
und wenn wenn Leute Suchtverhalten
entwickeln und wenn Leute sich da
irgendwie fieswechselseitig fertig
machen und so weiter das macht ja nicht
eher und das macht ja auch nicht seine
Firma und nicht seine Plattform und das
findet auf dieser Plattform statt mhm na
er könnte sagen wenn sich Leute im Bus
miteinander prügeln dann ist nicht der
der öffentliche Nahverkehr dafür
zuständig und der Busfahrer schon mal
gar nicht und auch nicht der Hersteller
des Autobusses das heißt also er weißt
im Grunde genommen die Verantwortung für
das was da passiert von sich mit
Argumenten die jetzt nicht gänzlich
erfunden sind mm sondern muss man sich
die Frage stellen welche schutzzeäune
könnte man denn aufbauen um das zu
verhindern und das wäre natürlich nur
eine Zensur der Inhalte und diese Zensur
der Inhalte ist man abgesehen von der
juristischen Schwierigkeit wie man die
Zäune zieht praktisch nahezu unmöglich
ich wüsste gar nicht wie sowas also wie
wie wie sollte denn da ein
Schutzprogramm Aussehen nach also klar
man kann natürlich bestimmte Begriffe
rausfiltern ne also massive
Beleidigungen könnte man eine ganzen
Katalog machen von Beleidigung
künstliche Intelligenz sperrt also
sofort alles wo diese Beleidigung
irgendwo drin vorkommen aber subtile
Form von Mobbing z.B könnte es überhaupt
nicht verhindern ja subtil nicht aber
ich weiß nicht wie es Dir geht ich ich
find's gut dass wir diese Debatte
endlich führen also sozusagen wer ist
verantwortlich für diese Inhalte was
macht das das auch mit unseren Kindern
was macht das mit unserer Gesellschaft
was macht das auch mit unserer
Demokratie diese Geschwindigkeit die da
ist die Inhalte die präsentiert werden
und so weiter und es gab im EU-Parlament
eine Befragung schon 2018 da damals
verhofstad gesagt wie soll man sich an
sie erinnern an Mark Zuckerberg
gerichtet an einen der drei großen
Internetgiganten also in einer Reihe mit
Steve Jobs und Bill Gates die unsere
Welt bereichert haben oder an das Genie
das ein digitales Monster geschaffen hat
das unsere Demokratie und Gesellschaft
zerstört das war
2018 und wenige Jahre später ein
bisschen dauert immer ja aber wenige
Jahre später ist die Debatte plötzlich
da ja es gibt gibt in den USA Florida
hat eine
Gesetzesvorlage auf den Weg gebracht die
dafür sorgen soll dass Jugendliche unter
16 grundsätzlich keinen Zugang mehr zu
Social Media haben wie will man das wie
will man das pass auf noch mal nur damit
du das ganze Bild hast interessant
könnte man sagen okay ist ist ist
Florida ja wir wissen da wer da wer da
am Berg ist und so weiter die die sind
gerade sehr sozusagen auf auf dem Weg in
die Vergangenheit was Schulbücher und so
weiter angeht ja Kreationisten die die
glauben dass Frauen aus der großartigen
Rippe eines noch großartigeren Mannes
gebastelt wurden und so weiter der
wiederum von einem noch großartigen
Geist geschaffen wurde richtig witig der
irgendwo im im im Himmel wohnt und alles
immer im Blick hat aber es gibt in 35
von 50 Bundesstaaten in Amerika
mittlerweile ähnliche Bestrebungen
sozusagen Kinder Gesellschaft vor
problematischen Inhalten im Netz zu
schützen und sie vom Bildschirm
wegzubringen gut das ist jetzt anders
als der Kreationismus ja ein nicht ganz
unredliches ansinn mich würde
interessieren wie viel realistische
Durchführbarkeit könnte der den besten
fallalls dahinter stehen wie soll das
wirklich funktionieren das ist die große
Frage interessant ist ja historisch ich
s die meine du hast dich doch mit dem
Thema auch öfter beschäftigt wenn wenn
sozusagen Politik das Gefühl hat da ist
etwas dass wir nicht mehr so richtig
kontrollieren können und es gibt ja
viele die Sagen facebook hat es auch dem
dem dem Team z.B von von Trump sehr sehr
leicht gemacht ja zu verstehen was die
Wähler wollen wer die Wähler sind und
sie dann auch entsprechend zu bedienen
und wenn man noch mal weiter zurückgeht
auch das Team von von Obama z.B die
haben als erste sozusagen ganz
systematisch Social Media genutzt um
Wahlkampf zu betreiben jetztöig
unabhängig von der Frage ob das jetzt
die aus unserer Sicht eher die Guten
oder eher die Bösen sind genau heutigen
Zeit ja kann niemand darauf verzichten
ja seinen kräftigen Fußabdruck in den
sozialen Netzwerken zu hinterlassen um
für sich zu werben richtig ja so und
wenn du dir das mal auch in in
Deutschland z.B anschaust
äh die die z.B die AFD ist im Internet
unglaublich groß jemand wie Ulrich
Sigmund von der AFD das der
kofraktionsvorsitzende aus SachsenAnhalt
der mittlerweile glaube ich auch
zugegeben hat dass er bei diesem Treffen
dain postam dabei war das so viel
berichtet wurde und dass ja irgendwie
auch was ausgelöst hat in der
Gesellschaft der gilt als
Nachwuchshoffnung in der AFD warum weil
er eine echte tiktokgröße ist der hat
glaube ich 360 70 000 Menschen die dort
seinem Account folgen das ist eine echte
macht ja gut also das sieht man ja in
den Kommentierungen auch auf Youtube
oder so dass die AFD da
überrepräsentiert ist so das ist
natürlich sie dürfen das ne und wenn sie
besonders viele
Anhänger Fans haben die das Bedürfnis
haben ihre Sichtweise auszubreiten und
andere Parteien nicht so viele davon
dann ist das ja in einer Demokratie
erstmal sozusagen ist das ja nicht
angreifbar ne man kann ja nicht
eine Kontrolle machen je nachdem W man
angehört oder sowas ob man sich irgendwo
äußern sollte oder wie repräsentiert man
in den sozialen Netzwerken ist es liegt
ein bisschen in der Natur der Sache dass
diejenigen die protestieren und dass
diejen die dagegen sind in den
Kommentarfunktionen und in den sozialen
Netzwerken überrepräsentiert sind sind
ja auch insgesamt die aggressiven
überrepräsentiert mm die die meisten
ausgerutenen gelassenen freundlichen
Menschen ja die in eine gewisse
Heiterkeit in sich tragen ja
kommentieren nicht es gibt's zwar auch
ja aber prozentual eben deutlich weniger
als diejenigen die verdammt schlechte
Laune haben das war schon früher beim
Leserbrief schreiben so leserbriefe
werden ja sehr selten so als Lob
geschrieben sondern es gab eine
bestimmte Klientele von schlecht
gelaunten Zeitgenossen die denken
dadurch dass sie mal Geld für eine
Zeitung bezahlt haben auch die Lizenz
erworben zu haben einen Redakteur nach
Herzenslust zu beschimpfen ja hast du
mal Leserbrief
geschrieben ich glaube ich habe einmal
ein Leserbrief geschrieben im soninger
TAGEBLATT so als oder 19 wirklich ja und
zwar gab es damals eine Debatte das
relativ viele Leute forderten wir
sollten doch bei der Nationalhymne die
erste Strophe wieder einführen kann man
sich heute gar nicht vorstellen war aber
eine Debatte ich rede jetzt ja über das
muss so 1985 gewesen sein ich auf jeden
Fall wurde das im soninger TAGEBLATT
eifrig diskutiert also nicht dass das
Tageblatt dafür war aber Leute die dafür
waren kamen da zu Wort und das war gab
es gab eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion
um die erste
und ich war absolut dagegen dass die
erste schufe wiederkommt und da hatte
ich meinen ersten Leserbrief geschrieben
und hast dort dagegen argumentti und
habort selbstverständlich dagegen
argumentiertagenumentiert interessant ja
und das ist mE es gab ja eine gewisse
Problematik der nationalhümme die auch
darin besteht dass man die zweite
Strophe nicht nehmen kann weil die
zweite Strophe ist eigentlich ehrlich
gesagt ein sauflied ja deutscher Wein
und deutsche Frauen das ist also so ein
ein schoi Männer saauflied Text der eben
auch nicht gesungen werden kann also die
erste strofe enthält lauter Grenzen die
nicht in Deutschland liegen die zweite
ist ein ein ein sentimentales
bestmöglich sag mal sentimental
ausgedrücktes sauflied und nur die
dritte Strophe ist wirklich schön das
heißt der der dritten waren wir dann
wieder klar im Kopf ja die dritte ist
natürlich eine wunderbare Lösung gewesen
die Alternative wäre gewesen sich eine
neue Hymne zu geben genau was man auch
hätte diskutieren können weil die alte
ja auch verbraucht war ne und und und
belastet war aber dein Vergleich mit mit
Leser ist schon interessant und wenn du
sagst da geht's darum laut zu sein
schnell zu sein hast du eine Idee wie
viele Abonnenten ungefähr ich ich ich
habe neich so so so ein paar Zahlen
gelesen die die sind mir wirklich häng
geblieben der YouTube-Kanal der AFD der
AFD Fraktion ne was schätzt du wie viele
Abonnenten hat er ungefähr boah
ungefähr 400.000 so das so die Zahl
interessant ist der Vergleich dazu die
SPD Fraktion bei YouTube wie viele
Abonnenten was schätzt du also ungefähr
400000 sein ja ja das werden sehr viel
weniger sein unter 100.000
4000 ja ist nicht schlecht und die Union
knapp 5000 ja und da siehst du wie sehr
sich sozusagen die die Debatte und
offensichtlich auch politischeer Erfolg
wie der sich ins Netz und zu zu zu zu
Social Media verlagert hat ne ja klar
weil also ich meine aus deren Sicht ja
sind sie in den anderen Medien nicht
emessen repräsentiert also suchen sich
die sozialmien und dort können sie sich
groß was aufbauen richtig wogegen die
anderen Parteien das Gefühl haben in den
anderen Medien hinreichend repräsentiert
zu sein und eigentlich gar nicht
brauchen mhm und dadurch gibt natürlich
das Netz ein völlig anderen politischen
Eindruck oder spiegelt den von
Deutschland wieder ja als
die lemedien z.B historisch wenn du mal
zurückblickst Richard so die Debatte um
um neue Medien ich ich würde sagen die
führen wir ja jetzt nicht zum ersten Mal
die Frage was sind das für Medien wie
bespielt man sie wie gehen wir damit um
und droht um noch mal auf letzte Woche
zu verweisen der Untergang des
Abendlandes mhm also zunächst mal jetzt
mal ohne apokalyptisch zu sein ne Medien
verändern immer die Demokratie ich meine
unsere repräsentative Demokratie die wir
haben so mit unserem Wahlrecht und
Gewaltenteilung und Rechtsstaatlichkeit
unsere Institutionen mehrere Kammern und
so das stammt ja eigentlich alles aus im
18 Jahrhundert also da hat man sich das
ausgedacht und im 19 Jahrhundert hat
sich das dann in zahlreichen Ländern in
England schon vorher dann irgendwie
durchgesetzt und dann wurde der Kreis
der Wahlberechtigten immer größer erst
nur die Reichen nur Männer und dann kam
irgendwann auch die ärmeren und dann
schließlich auch noch die Frauen dazu
und so weiter und das hat sich alles
geeben aber die DNA so die Grundstruktur
die ist ja eigentlich schon sehr alt und
die stammt ja aus einer Zeit in der die
Medienlandschaft mit der heutigen nicht
zu vergleichen war und das Spannende ist
ja dass Demokratien überhaupt erst
möglich waren als es möglich war
Informationen zu
verbreiten und Bildung also ohne
Information und Bildung kann ja
Demokratie nicht funktionieren das
machtte keinen Sinn im Mittelalter eine
Demokratie zu fordern mhm ja außer in
kleinen Gemeinschaften also wo man sich
auf Augenhöhe trifft in dem Dorf oder so
ne so auf so kleinen Ebenen so
Urchristentum kommunistische
kleingemeinschaften oder irgendwie sowas
ja oder oder früher eben das alte Athen
wo sich alle wichtigen Leute auf
Marktplatz trafen aber dann über ganz
ganz lange Zeit ging das ja gar nicht
mehr also noch rousseau war der Ansicht
dass man die Demokratie nur in in in in
kleinen Städten einführen kann aber
nicht in ganz Frankreich mit dem damals
jetzt nicht abwegigen Argument dass die
Leute ja überhaupt nicht politisch
informiert sind also wenn es dann
Parteien gibt und Leute gibt und so
weiter war wo hat denn der Bauer die
Gelegenheit der nicht lesen kann ja und
der auch keine Zeitung oder so liest was
ja nur eine ganz kleine Schicht damals
überhaupt gemacht hat ja wie soll der
sich denn überhaupt informieren wen er
wählen soll der kann ja noch nicht mal
den Wahlzettel lesen und deswegen ist
natürlich klar dass eine funktionierende
Demokratie darauf angewiesen sind dass
möglichst viele Leute in der Lage sind
qualifiziert mitzureden und dafür
braucht er es natürlich ein
entsprechendes Mediensystem und es
braucht eine allgemeine Bildung so und
dann passierte es natürlich dass diese
dieses Mediensystem und auch die
lightmedien also was lightmedium jeweils
war sich stark veränderten es gibt
unheimlich viele Untersuchungen darüber
wie die Nazis den rundf genutzt haben
der Volksempfänger ne der Volksempfänger
ja das wurde ja richtig vorangetrieben
ja damit jeder Hitlers reden hören
konnte und die Nazipropaganda ins Haus
geliefert be Radio ne die sousagen die
sozusagen systematische also
massenkompatible Nutzung von Radio ne
darum geh dann kam das Fernsehen ne und
das ja auch von von sehr ambivalent
wahrgenommen wurde es wurde von sehr
vielen intelligenten Menschen von Anfang
an als verdummungsmedium gesehen meine
Eltern übrigens auch meine auch
also egal ob jetzt links oder oder
rechts war oder ob konservativ oder
progressiv war ja und und wir durften
also nur unglaublich wenig fernsehen
gucken ja um nicht zu verdummen und
m das Fernsehen veränderte auch ganz
viel ich weiß also das war so ein
Lieblingsthema von Helmut Schmidt ja der
dann immer von der fernsehdemokratie
sprach mm ja um zu sagen fdemokratie
nicht wertschätzen und immer sagt auf
fernsehdemokratie hat andere Spielregeln
ja da geht es um Politik V Markt wo man
mal sagen muss er selber war in Genie in
politikvermarktung ja aber für ihn war
das schon so so ein bisschen eine
Beeinträchtigung der Demokratie dass man
da im Fernsehen saß und und sich
verkaufen musste im Grunde genommen
sympathisch rüberkommen oder besonders
klug oder wie auch immer für ihn fand
Demokratie im Parlament statt ja und
nicht in der Elefantenrunde oder so wo
der sich da mit dem Kohl da angeraunzt
hat und sich den Zigarettenqualm ins
Gesicht geblasen haben dann kam das
Privatfernsehen dann kam das
privatfernehen ein riesiges Politikum ja
es gibt ja
auch von von Schmidt den Satz ja
Privatfernsehen ist gefährlicher als
Atomstrom damals gab's die große Debatte
um Kernenergie ja und alle alle hatten
Angst vor Kernkraftwerken und er hat
überhaupt keine Angst er hat das Massiv
vorangetrieben aber er hatte Angst vor
dem Privatfernsehen dass im Grunde alles
auseinander fliegt ja und wie habmlos
war das Privatfernsehen noch mal im
Vergleich ja zur internetrevolution die
dann danach kam und während unsere
repräsentative
Demokratie immer noch das modifizierte
Modell des 18 Jahrhundert war leben wir
heute in einer Medienwelt wo die Väter
die sich mal die liberale Demokratie
ausgedacht haben repräsentative
Demokratie ja in ihren allerkühnsten
Träumen oder Albträumen gar nicht darauf
gekommen wären wie Öffentlichkeit mal im
21 jahrhund aussieht und jetzt müssen
wir versuchen das zusammenzukriegen und
wenn ich das ganz einfach darstellen
kann kann man sagen regieren ist umso
leichter ja je weniger Leute sich an
Politik beteiligen und Ahnung haben ja
umgekehrt ist eine Demokratie ihrem
Prinzip nach umso mehr Demokratie je
mehr Leute sich daran beteiligen und
Ahnung haben und jetzt stehen wir vor
der schwierigen Situation dass ganz ganz
ganz viele Leute völlig egal wie
qualifiziert oder unqualifiziert sich am
politischen Meinungsbildungsprozess
öffentlich beteiligen können und das
macht aus der Sicht der regierenden
regieren wahnsinnig schwierig parallel
mit der Explosion von Informationen ist
das Ansehen der Politiker gesunken mm ja
weil ein ein Kaiser Wilhelm wenn man ihn
mal Politiker nannte ja den hat kaum ein
deutscher je persönlich zu Gesicht
bekommen da kannte man nur extrem
gestellte Fotos auf dem Pferd ja oder in
der Sonne
stehend wenn dieser Mann in eine
Talkshow gegangen wäre ja klein bisschen
verwachsen eine Fistelstimme ja bisschen
hysterisch und äußerst unkonzentriert ja
hätte niemand in dem Kaiser eine große
Person gesehen das heißt die Aura Kaiser
Wilhelms basierte einzig und allein
darauf dass man von dem als Mensch gar
keine Vorstellung hatte heute sind
Politiker in allem völlig präsent und
siee da es bleibt kein einziger Held
mehr übrig mhm ja wie muss man denn sein
dass man völlig unangreifbar und
auratisch und all sowas ist das geht nur
wenn die Leute nicht besonders viel über
ein wissen wenn man e nicht so genau
kennt und so weiter das erleichtert das
Regieren mm im demokratischen Sinne
haben wir eine ganz tolle Entwicklung
gemachtau aber wir Erle absolut tolle
Entwicklung aber wir erleben ja dass
regieren fast unmöglich wird und ich
habe immer größere Befürchtung also wir
haben jetzt eine nicht sonderlich
funktionale Regierung aus drei Parteien
wir werden nach der nächsten
Bundestagswahl mit sehr sehr hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit wieder eine Koalition
aus drei Parteien haben und die Gefahr
dass die dann nachdem wir jetzt die
unbeliebteste Regierung aller Zeiten
haben dann zur allerunbeliebtesten
Regierung aller Zeiten wird ist ziemlich
groß mhm das ist eine ziemlich
schwierige Situation in die wir da
geraten sind so jetzt habe ich natürlich
einen weiten Weg gemacht von Facebook am
Anfang dahin ich will nur einfach sagen
dass die informationsexplosion und
beteiligungsexplosion Demokratie
theoretisch ein Traum ist aber was die
pragmatische Kunst des Regierens und des
damit Umgehens das ständig also
Erregungswellen und Empörung und
Verurteilung und soas gehört ja auch
alles dazu ja unter diesem Druck und
unter dieser ständigen Drohkulisse was
muss man für ein Mensch sein um da noch
Politiker sein zu wollen und welche
Handlungsfähigkeit hat man noch mhm ja
und dann wird's halt eben schwierig
sozusagen wenn die das ist ja ganz
interessant ne was du da beschrieben
hast also Radio Fernsehen und dann rein
ins Netz ich weiß noch ich habe vor ein
paar Jahren mal tierischen Ärger
gekriegt schon wirklich viele Jahre her
weil ich gesagt habe das Fernsehen per
se meiner Ansicht nach zumindest ein
eher oberflächliches Medium ist im Sinne
von
du musst sozusagen in diesem in diesem
kurzen oon wie das ja dann heißt ja auf
15 20 Sekunden musst du irgendwie
funktionieren wenn du da deine Botschaft
nicht gesetzt hast funktioniert die
ganze Geschichte nicht ganz anders
dagegen ein ausgeruhtes langes Stück
langes Interview sozusagen in der Zeit
oder auch im Stern oder im Spiegel oder
wo auch immer oder in der Süddeutschen
ja da kannst du deine Argumente darlegen
kannst Gegenargumente dann entkräften
oder dir anhören oder wie auch immer man
kann sich über lange Zeit sozusagen eine
Meinung bilden und wenn du irgendwas
nicht genau verstanden hast oder mit
einem Argument möglicherweise nicht ganz
klar bist dann gehst du einfach noch mal
zurück und liest es noch mal und dann
hast du es möglicherweise verstanden ja
oder du liest woanders noch du nimst es
auch tiefer auf wenn du es liest ja
genau ja als also ich meine das ist auch
auch völlig klar das was man sieht und
gesprochen ist und dann kommt die
nächste Sendung und dann guckt man noch
ein krimmi danach und so und dann bleibt
da irgendwie eine homöopathische Dosis
davon zurückau wenn man sich tatsächlich
die Mühe gemacht hat ein langes
Interview zu lesen bleibt davon ziemlich
viel im Regelfall zurück und auch für
längere Zeit das stimmt schon ja das
meine ich ne und das meine ich mit
oberflächlich natürlich kann man auch im
Fernsehen versuchen in die Tiefe zu
gehen aber Menschen funktionieren nach
im Fernsehen nach anderen
Gesetzmäßigkeiten als beispielsweise in
in einem Magazin oder Zeitungsinterview
man muss nur eine blöde Krawatte anhaben
ja und dann ist man die Leute erstmal
abgelenkt und gucken erstmal fragen hat
er denn irgendwie wer berätt den denn
eigentlich da bei seiner krawat und so
weiter und hat man schon bei der Hälfte
der Aussage nicht zugehört ja und ich
ich für mich ein ein unglaublich
lehrreicher Moment diesbezüglich war der
Moment Corona und wir haben plötzlich
kein Publikum mehr im Studio und diese
ganze Sendung funktioniert plötzlich
nach nach ganz anderen Gesetzmäßigkeiten
die hat nie einer aufgeschrieben die hat
nie einer festgelegt aber plötzlich
funktionierte das ganze Ding nach einer
soagen
geheimnisvoll und in die Wahrheit gar
nicht vorhandenen inneren Dramaturgie ja
die Leute was weiß ich jemand wie ein
Wolfgang kubiki der so ein der ist ja
auch so der ist auch sehr unterhaltsam
zum Teil dann dann ist auch wieder ein
Schowi dann ist ein begnadeter
Entertainer einer wie Wolfgang kubiki
ich weiß noch wie der die ersten Mal in
diesem Studio waren plötzlich war dieser
Resonanzkörper dieses Publikum war quasi
nicht mehr da und es lachte keiner mehr
wenn er dann mal wieder einen
rausgehauen hat das war für den eine
völlig neuartige Erfahrung war
interessant oder auch jemand wie weiß
ich Marie Agnes stind viele FDP da fällt
mir gerade auf Marie Agnes stzimmermann
und andere ja oder oder auch jemand wie
Sarah Wagenknecht z.B funktioniert ja
auch sehr mit über diese Triggerpunkte
die sie setzt und und weiß genau jetzt
sage ich irgendeinen Satz gegen den
niemand etwas haben kann und zack kommt
der Applaus wenn der Applaus plötzlich
ausbleibt dann passiert etwas mit den
Leuten und auch in diesem Studio dann
geht's plötzlich viel härter und auch
viel klarer um das Gute Argument und und
du merkst das so so ein populistischer
Satz ja einer der der immer ging ein Gag
der immer funktioniert hat irgend so ein
so ein weiß ich nicht auch ich wie
Wolfgang bossbach ja auch so so ein
begnadeter Entertainer Gregor Gisi ja
Gregor Gesi z.B genau die tun sich dann
plötzlich schwerer weil weil natürlich
die die die anderen die da sitzen ja die
anderen Gäste Profis ja die die Fallen
drauf nicht rein ja die die die die
kennen das Argument damit will ich nicht
sagen dass die die im Studio sitzen auf
irgendetwas reinfallen aber es es
unterhält
ja und und jemand von der politischen
Konkurrenz der lacht schon allein
deswegen nicht weil er nicht mitlachen
will an einer Stelle ja wo es gut ist
für eine andere Partei allein deswegen
lacht er nicht das irritiert die Leute
das ist total interessant das zu erleben
und seitdem hab ist mein Gefühl wird
ernsthafter und auch auch fokussierter
um das Gute Argument gerungen das ist
schon sehr interessant wie möchtest du
das was du gerade beschrieben hast also
den Geist im wohlmeinenden Streit um das
Gute Argument zu ringen wie willst du
den in die sozialen Netzwerke
implementieren das große Thema ne weil
da ist ja gibt's ja auch sowas wie den
schnell heranrauschenden Applaus und das
sind die Leute die sofort drauf springen
und es kommentieren und je steiler meine
Aussage umso höher ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie kommentiert
wird also größer ist die Resonanz mhm
ich habe dieser Tage weil ich viel
gelesen habe so über diesen diesen
Geburtstag daavon Facebook und so ist ja
mittlerweile Meta ja das ist ein ein
riesiger Konzern Akti nähert sich gerade
wieder dem Rekord hoch und so weiter
wird wahnsinnig viel Geld verdient
obwohl sie immer wieder tot gesagt
worden sind aber das läuft gerade
richtig so und wenn man wenn man das
liest dann spielt eine ganz
entscheidende Rolle für den Erfolg von
Facebook das ist jemanden wie mir der da
nicht zu Hause ist und nicht viel mit zu
tun hat völlig unklar dieser like
bututton Daumen hoch mm also Zustimmung
und und das ist auch einer der
kernvorwürfe von dieser dieser dieser
Anhörung auch im im US-Kongress gewesen
und das auch glaube ich ein Thema dass
das viele Medienfachleute auf der Welt
so umtreibt die Frage der der der
Abhängigkeit was machen diese Apps mit
uns was macht diese Form von Zustimmung
mit uns ja die
Belohnungssysteme die im Gehirn
aktiviert werden Dopamin das quasi
ausgeschüttet wird und eigentlich ist
die Idee und ich erinnere mich da an ein
Gespräch 2021 mit soem Investor in San
Francisco ich glaube ich habe dir die
Geschichte schon mal erzählt der damals
sagte ihr habt immer so eine naive
Vorstellung ihr glaubt da sitzen so ein
paar Computer Nerds zusammen und wir
programmieren dann mal so lustig vor uns
hin und unterhalten uns sozusagen vor
allen Dingen auf einer technischen Ebene
wenn wir uns darüber austauschen was das
nächste große Ding werden könnte was die
nächste interessante App ist aber was
wir in Wahrheit machen ist wir reden mit
Psychologen wir reden mit
Neurowissenschaftlern wir reden mit
Leuten die von Psychologie etwas
verstehen äh und Zuckerberg ist äh
jemand der unter anderen Psychologie
studiert hat bevor das alles abgebrochen
hat und kommt auch aus einer
psychologenfamilie der versteht was von
Psycholog und hat diesen diesen Like
Button irgendwann eingeführt kriegt ihr
dann immer wieder die Forderung dann
führ doch auch an den dislike button ein
also Daumen nach unten hat er nie
gemacht mhm ich habe eine Idee warum er
das nie gemacht hat weil du natürlich du
willst das andere du willst die
Zustimmung Zustimmung Zustimmung
Zustimmung Belohnung Belohnung und du
willst niemandem sagen was das mögen wir
jetzt aber alles g gen dann hören die
Leute auf ne sich zu beteiligen wenn sie
zu oft ein ein Daumen runter gekriegt
haben genau genau ist total interessant
ja und so ist das ja so eine kleine
dopaminmaschine ne man schreibt was und
dann kriegt man Anerkennung dafür und
man kriegt ja auch wenn man
beleidigt sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit und
findet auch immer wieder Freunde die
sich darüber kaputt lachen und das auch
großartig find einen draufsetzen und so
und da werden natürlich bestimmte
Charaktereigenschaften gefördert und
gepinselt nicht immer bestimte
politische Überzeugungen verstärken sich
unter Umständen noch durch den Zuspruch
den man bekommt ne der echokammereffekt
der da Eintritt ja aber jetzt
interessiert mich natürlich die Frage
das was wir hier gerade erzählen ist
natürlich nicht nur von uns jetzt mal
beschrieben worden sondern schon ganz
oft beschrieben und die spannende Frage
es muss ja ein Grund gegeben haben warum
es die Anhörung gab oder warum man jetzt
über Gesetze nachdenkt wie man
verhindert dass unter 16 jährige sich
darumtreibenm was glaubst du denn kann
man realistisch machen also ich hatte
bisher immer so den eruck wir haben die
Büchse der Pandora geöffnet genau ne wir
haben auch es ist ja auch nicht so als
ob das was auf den sozialen Netzwerken
sich abspielt jetzt
ausnahmenslos radikale Ansichten sind
oder Vorurteile oder oder Mobbing und so
weiter ne aber es ist natürlich
einfacher möglich gewesen das hinaus in
die Welt zu pusten mm was glaubst du
denn also ich meine alles was ich mir in
meinem Kopf vorstellen kann an
Einschränkungen an Zensur und sowas
alles ist erstmal irrsinnig aufwendig
wahrscheinlich unheim leicht zu umgehen
und als drittes wahrscheinlich auch noch
juristisch problematisch nicht alles
aber vieles davon ne dass man dann denkt
jetzt wird das auch noch alles zensiert
und das geht gegen die Meinungsfreiheit
und das wird ganz ganz viele Leute
empören ja weil sie das Gefühl haben
hier soll Meinung kanalisiert werden ist
ja auch die Frage wer beurteilt das was
eine radikale Meinung ist da hat jeder
eine andere Meinung zu ja also ich kann
mir überhaupt gar keine ernstzunehben
Regulierung leider
vorstellen also wenn man noch mal
sozusagen den den größeren bogenpannt ne
du hast das eben gerade auch gemacht und
sozusagen mal die die die Grundlagen mal
klärt dann versteht man glaube ich noch
besser wie komplex das alles ist also
welche Fehleinschätzungen auch die
geteilt haben die es quasi erfunden
haben wobei das im Fall von sakaburger
durchaus auch umstritten ist wie wir
damals ja in the social network gesehen
haben
was er erfunden hat und was andere ERF
genau ob er es erfunden hat oder ob es
jemand anderer war aber er ist
jedenfalls das Genie das dann sehr genau
begriffen hat was die Leute so lange wie
möglich dran hält sackerberg hat in den
Anfangsjahren mal gesagt dass die
Verbreitung der sozialen Medien den
Terrorismus im Nahen Osten beenden wird
und zwar mit der Begründung man kann
sich schließlich nicht hassen wenn man
miteinander verbunden ist diese
sozialarbeiterlyyrik ja die ist so
falsch ja die ist nur wirklich falsch ja
also das diese dieser dieser
teestubensatz ja dass man denkt die
ganze Aggression der Menschen
untereinander rühre doch einzig und
allein daher dass man nicht genug ja
über sich und über den anderen weiß und
miteinander redet so nach dem Motto
redet mal miteinander sind die Konflikte
weg ich meine es ist noch nicht lange
her da war die Weihnachtszeit ja da
kommen Menschen miteinander zusammen und
sind dann sozusagen weil sie Familie
sind was nicht unbedingt heißt dass man
sich leiden kann zusammen auf engstem
Raum und normalerweise redet man da ganz
ganz viel miteinander und bei ganz
vielen Leuten gibt es Weihnachten Streit
ja und es gibt viel weniger Streit wenn
man sich nicht sieht aber in dem Moment
iner
eht viel mehr es ist doch doch einfach
nicht wahr dass der Hass ja und die
Aggression einzig und allein darauf
zurückzuführen ist dass man nicht genug
miteinander redet sich nicht genug
austauscht es kann sogar sein dass wenn
man wirklich viel miteinander redet der
Hass und die Aggression noch sehr viel
größer wird also das ist eine ganz
eigenartige Vorstellung wobei man ich
nie genau weiß ja ob jemand wie zuckerbg
das wirklich selber geglaubt hat ja oder
ob das typisch Silicon Valley ja nicht
auch einfach so ein schöner
vermarktungsspruch ist um dem Ganzen so
ein heilenschein aufzusetzen ja das ist
aber wenn du mal überlegst ne also
sousagen gab ja damals auch die
erinnerst du dich es gab doch auch immer
dieses diese große Erzählung der
arabische Frühling es waren vor allen
Dingen die sozialen Netzwerke die die
den vorangebracht haben heute weiß man
ja aus der Forschung ist auch sehr
interessant dass dass die guten alten
klassischen Medien Fernsehen und Radio
dabei eine viel größere Rolle gespielt
haben als soziale Netzwerke man braucht
do eigentlich zialen Netzwerke damals um
sich möglichst schnell verabreden zu
können so aber ich meine es ja nicht so
als ob es keine Großdemos gegeben hätte
in den Zeiten bevor es das Internet gab
oder soziale Netzwerke das können sich
junge Menschen wahrscheinlich heute gar
nicht vorstellen als da im Bonner
Hofgarten 300.000 Leute gegen NAT
doppelbeschluss protestiert ja
protestiert hab
ja als per Telefon und man wusste dass
und aus der Schule und es gab so viele
andere Kanäle dass man das wusste und
dass sie dahin kamen und es gab bestimmt
kein einzigen der gedacht hätte oh da
wäre ich wahnsinnig gern hingegangen ich
habe leider nichts davon mitgekriegt
über Wochen war das ein großes Thema
immer und überall und zwar ohne Internet
und ohne soziale Netzwerke und da habe
ich auch beim arabischen Frühling immer
gedacht wird das hier gerade nicht
maßlos überschätzt ist das nicht eine
indirekte Werbekampagne für soziale
Netzwerke genau ja ja die das ist ja der
Punkt ne die die die Frage der Erzählung
wer etabliert welches narrativ wie man
heute sagen würde ich find's nur so
interessant also wie sich da fundamental
was in der Wahrnehmung geändert hat ja
also von von dem Satz aus den
Anfangsjahren das wird den Terror im
Nahen Osten beenden weil man kann sich
nicht hassen wenn man doch miteinander
so nett verbunden ist bis hin zu
lindseay Graham der diesem
republikanischen Senator der Zuckerberg
jetzt in dieser Senatsanhörung an den
Kopf geworfen hat wirklich den Satz sie
haben Blut an ihren Händen sie haben ein
Produkt das Menschen tötet so krass ja
also das ist das ist sozusagen es ist
ist ein gewisser weg und interessant ist
auch so Untersuchungen aus anderen
Ländern ne aus die Kollegen vom
Tagesspiegel Jungs berichtet Polen
Spanien Taiwan und so weiter wo eben
Parteien festgestellt haben dass Ihre
Inhalte auf der Plattform eben nur dann
viele Menschen erreichen wenn sie
richtig provokativ sind das erklärt
natürlich auch diese
z kenn die Bildzeitung Seite sie gibt ja
genau ja und deswegen aber änderst du
das ist ja das interessante du änderst
ja nicht nur die Kommunikation
ist ja se große Frage änderst du einfach
nur deine Kommunikation wirst du
schneller wirst du direkter einfach
anders mehr videogetrieben und so weiter
oder änderst du sozusagen ganze
politische
Programme das ist ja dann der nächste
Schritt das ist die Gefahr die darin
steht also wenn du wahnsinnig viel
Applaus kriegst dafür ne also je je
härter und radikaler du bist umso größer
wird der Applaus dann färbt das wiederum
auf auf deine Programmatik ab weil du
direkt siehst was funktioniert mhm genau
und weißt du da muss ich noch mal noch
mehr Stoff geben und noch mehr Stoff und
so das kann also also wir wollen ja
nicht so tun als hätte es vor
internetzeiten und vor Zeiten der
sozialen Netzwerke nicht auch
Radikalisierungen gegeben ja und zwar
nicht zu knapp ne also sie K die
kollektive Radikalisierung Deutschland
die zum Dritten Reich geführt hat das
alles hat es ohne die sozialen Netzwerke
gegeben da haben auch andere andere
Möglichkeiten zu ausgereicht Propaganda
zu verbreiten wir wir haben wir können
das heute schneller subtiler und
effizienter machen als das in früheren
Zeiten war D dadurch kriegt das Ganze
eine gespenstischere Dimension wir
können wir können programmierte Bots
loslassen ja die Millionen von
Kommentaren machen und anderen den
Eindruck suggerieren ja das wäre eine
wahnsinnig weit verbreitete Meinung
richtig ja dann können das natürlich
ausländische Mächte können sich überall
einschalten und und Meinung mit
beeinflussen auf eine viel subtilere Art
und Weise als es vorher möglich war das
ist alles so aber ich komme wieder zu
meiner lieblingsfrage zurück ja da ich
keine realistischen zensurmöglichkeiten
sehe ja und das ist eine offene Frage
also ich lasse mich ja gerne belehren
und ich lerne gerne dazu was es für
tolle Möglichkeiten gibt das Monster zu
zähmen aber ich ich habe bisher den
Eindruck sowas richtig gutes ist einem
da nicht eingefallen ich hätte da so ein
so ein Gedanken den ich auch über den
ich auch häufiger mal stolpere dazu
gleich mehr aber ich will dir noch mal
recht geben in dieser Frage sozusagen es
ist viel passgenauer es es ist viel
subtiler und deswegen ist auch sozusagen
die Manipulation als solche auch finde
ich sehr viel schwerer zu erkennen zu
dekodieren aber du warst bei der Frage
Richard was kann man tun ich würde immer
sagen und das ist etwas was ich mich
seit langer Zeit
Frage wir beide haben es auch schon
erlebt in der Sendung ist es genauso
jede Zeitung jeder Verlag alle sind
sozusagen für das verantwortlich was sie
publizieren du bist dafür verantwortlich
ich kann nicht sagen in meiner Sendung
sagt irgendjemand etwas was sozusagen
weil sie nicht Volksverhetzung ist oder
was auch immer und ich lass das dann
einfach so stehen lass das so durchgehen
dann geht das mit mir nach Hause dann
geht das im Zweifel auch mit dem ZDF
nach Hause ich bin verantwortlich für
die Verbreitung dieses Inhalts das ist
sehr interessant bei Meta bei Marx
sackeberg ist das anders sag pass auf
also wir liefern ja nur das schöne
Werkzeug wir liefern die Plattform aber
was die Leute dort jetzt genau machen
sorry was haben wir damit zu tun mm da
gab's ja dann immer denwei zu sagen
warum also musst es doch zumindestens
Echtnamen Kennzeichnungspflicht machen
und ähm in den sozialen Netzwerken
müssen die Plattformen zumindestens über
die Adresse verfügen und und da hat man
dann sofort gesagt ja wenn das soweit
ist dann trauen sich die Leute da nicht
mehr ihre politische Meinung zu sagen
aus Angst dass das ja rückverfolgt
werden kann mhm na das war immer das
Gegenargument dagegen ich habe ja auch
Anfang überze ich könte mir am Anfang
ich konnte mir am Anfang überhaupt nicht
verstanden warum es diese Anonymisierung
überhaupt gibt ja also warum darf jemand
in und soziale Netzwerke sind
Öffentlichkeit in der Öffentlichkeit
über jemanden herfallen in der
lächerlich preiskeit Preis geben und so
weiter ohne dafür seinen Kopf hinhalten
zu müssen mhm das ist auch fest meine
Überzeugung gewesen ich habe dann
natürlich im Zusammenhang meiner
Beschäftigung mit Digitalisierung mit
vielen Menschen gesprochen die mir
versucht haben zu erklären warum das
durchaus seinen Sinn hat dass das so ist
eben aus dem einfachen Grund weil die
Leute sich dann davon wieder
verabschieden weil sie sich ja nicht
richtig trauen ihre Meinung zu sagen und
so andererseits ich meine äh wenn meine
Meinung darin besteht Dinge in die
Öffentlichkeit zu blasen für die ich im
zweifelswah nicht gerade stehen möchte
dann sollte ich vielleicht diese Meinung
so auch nicht verbreiten so das doch der
Punkt ja das doch der Punkt und ich
glaube da wäre auf jeden Fall definitiv
ein Hebel aber aber du merkst du hast es
vorhin so formuliert ne der Geist ist
aus der Flasche sich wahnsinnig schwer
in wieder reinzukriegen und ich finde
Richard abschließend noch mal gesagt wir
wir sollten
uns mal in dem Zusammenhang
speziellusagen Kindern und Jugendlichen
widmen nicht jetzt wie zwei alte Oppers
die irgendwie jetzt schlaue Ratschläge
verteilen so pädagogisch wertvoll und so
weiter sondern es geht ganz and zu Hause
und so genau ja genau aber es ist der
Kampf den Eltern jeden Tag führen es
gibt mittlerweile Kinder die die fahren
mit gespreizten Zeigefinger und Daumen
über ein Kinderbuch um die Zeichnung zu
vergrößern ja und andere tippen eine
Banane an weil sie im onlinpiel gelernt
haben man kann die so schälen
beispielsweise oder abschießen ja es
gibt es gibt eine Studie aus Japan die
zeigt dass ein Drittel und jetzt reden
wir von ein gen Kindern täglich ein bis
zwei Stunden vor dem Bildschirm
verbringt himelön so und ja ist so und
das heißt die Frage die 30 Jahre nach
dem Durchbruch des Internets und 20
Jahre nach der Geburt von Facebook immer
mehr Menschen umtreibt Wissenschaftler
Eltern und so weiter ist die Frage wie
viel Bildschirm verträgt die Kindheit so
so haben es neulich die Kollegen in der
in
der verträgt die Bildung ne auch
spannende Frage was ist mit Bildschirm
in Schule und so weiter genau dann dazu
die Meldung dass in skandinavischen
Ländern gerade alles wieder
rückabgewickelt wird mE Schweden war der
Vorreiter in dem Bereich eines sollte
digit weiß dasich gut meine Schwester
ist der Lehrerin so und jetzt verteilen
die plötzlich wieder Bücher und Kinder
gucken da drauf und sagen das ist ja
völlig irre wir kriegen jetzt mal ganz
aufregend ein Buch in die Hand also der
Kampf sozusagen um ein um eine analoge
um ein bisschen analoges
aufwachsen das ist ein total
interessanter interessante Geschichte ja
das hat viele Dimensionen viele
Dimensionen ne Chat GPT und Schule ganz
ganz spannendes Thema genau ich finde da
sollten wir demnächsten mal drüber reden
in diesem Sinne viel Spaß weiterhin in
deiner Kemenate ja danke danke und ich
versuche irgendwie diesen Hamburger
Winter irgendwie wie soll man sagen
nicht allzu dun heutig zu übersmen genau
zu ertragen ja Zwiebelprinzip einfach
noch eine Schicht mehr wenn es gar nicht
mehr geht Richard dank dir sehr ja
Tschüss markus hat Spaß gemacht bis
dahin eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF